Jeff Garlin actor-comedian yes
performing at Caroline's on Broadway
tomorrow through Sunday yes you can
catch him on the Goldbergs as well as
HBO's Curb Your Enthusiasm the new
season and it's it's my favorite season
we've ever done of Curb what would
surprise me in kirb a lot of gentle
lovemaking you and Larry but I have to
say here's the thing it's what you want
and what you're used to but the premise
without giving it away is something that
everyone is experienced and said I wish
I could and Larry David does that's a
good tease there yeah that's what the
premises and it is delightful I love it
because last year we had last season we
had the fakhla that for my personal
taste that was a bit big I like the
subtle ones yes the ones that are human
nature and stuff and this is truly
everybody has experienced this and said
I wish I could and Larry David does best
cameo on curb turned in by who jeez you
know I can't give any of those away for
this year well you're not due this year
okay past historically geez
Muggsy Bogues Richard Louis I think and
Larry looking at his wiener that that's
one of my favorites and he was just such
a sport yeah yeah that was a good person
I've ever window he just said Weiner on
me by the way let me tell you something
want to be really sincere on this that
I'm talking to men everywhere
don't say the other words for a penis
okay don't okay when you're talking to a
woman if you say touch my blankety-blank
a woman's gonna go what'd you say
would you touch my wiener he's gonna say
no they're all gonna say yes I'll be
there sure Weiner it's delightful and
then when you go to bed
they say I'll be right back I have to
make a [ __ ] what is wrong with you
today nothing I have a career what's
wrong with me today do you know what
your stand-up act tomorrow night is
gonna be I have no idea I will have no
idea as I'm walking to the stage I will
have no idea it might be you know I
don't have an introduction there's no
emcee when I work and I play a different
song every time I walk up to the stage
and sometimes that song I tell the
audience who it is and about the song
and sometimes the lyrics and who wrote
it and that'll lead me to think of
something which leads me to something
else in something else and then because
I have complete supreme confidence that
I'm funny so I don't worry about
anything else
I brought this up to Jonah Hill and and
it didn't go over well but I said do
people find you less funny when you lose
weight right and he had gotten skinny
yes and I maybe I didn't present it in
the right way but he was saying Dan how
could you say that but I'm just curious
person how could you say you know I love
Jonah Hill I truly have loved him if I
could spend more time with him
I tell him to stop taking himself
seriously I always tell my children take
what you do seriously don't take
yourself seriously he should have left
and said and dealt with it and the
reality is I could be 170 or 370
although 370 I might look a bit
uncomfortable I'm funny no matter what
weight has nothing to do with it the
thing about weight that can help certain
people who aren't as funny is it makes
you more vulnerable and more accessible
when you're heavier yeah you know
there's barley yes but Chris would have
been funny at any weight Chris was just
funny period you ever worked with him
yeah yeah I mean I actually replaced him
at second city
I left second city for a while and when
I came back he was you know they
and brilliant and funny and he went to a
so now yeah he was funny no matter what
who's this guy you saw first time you
saw him he went oh my god without a
doubt when I saw him and you know it's
so funny no one you'd think everybody
would be talking about somebody
everyone's so concerned with themselves
they don't look at others I love
laughing at other people and looking
those and there's one person who was
supremely I think supreme twice I've
never said it and I hate the store
supreme I went by the way yesterday I
needed a sweatshirt I went in to supreme
they made me wait in line and then they
mock you when you're in line the doorman
mocks you should I let everybody and
he's talking out loud like what kind of
power game of you and then I go inside
they have no selection anyhow the one
person I saw at second city that truly
when I say from the first second blew me
away was Steve Carell Steve Carell was
so amazing that I couldn't believe it he
was doing some characters amazed but he
did then he went to Dana Carvey show yes
and then he got the office after that
yes yes and have you seen that
documentary on on that show I don't know
here's the thing I watch that show I
know everything went on behind the
scenes of Robert Smigel
is a very close friend of mine so I knew
all that stuff I knew everything
so between knowing the behind-the-scenes
and seeing the show when it aired
because it was my friends
I knew all that stuff and yes it was
fascinating that it failed with those
people
he's a Jeff Garlin you can see him at
Caroline's on Broadway tomorrow through
Sunday of course the Goldbergs in HBO's
Curb Your Enthusiasm yes I've been
mentioning this Lakers situation and
during the commercial break you said
that you have totally got chance to sit
next to Jerry Willis here's the here's
the thing I've been a Bulls fan my life
okay my whole life it's like the Knicks
I don't you can't expect me to keep
going and support a team when you showed
such disrespect and the Knicks are worse
than the Bulls and the Bulls enough with
how they destroyed that team so when I
went to hell
numerous people said hey and by the way
former Knick fans who Doug Roberts and
it produces the goal but for one for
sure come on to the Knicks come over to
the Knicks so I started going to the
knick games and I'm having a ball and
I'm like this is a team I start watching
every game one night I'm at the I'm at
the Staples Center and I meet mr. Baumer
and he's a delight and he invites me to
go to a game with him so about three
weeks ago
I went to the game had dinner with mr.
Baumer before the game set and with him
during the game Jerry West to my right
spent it talked to Jerry West during the
game and a half time I talked with Jerry
West Jerry West who I always look at
from the stands going look at how
focused he is he's stoic and he knows
every nuance which by the way he does
know every nuance but that dude ain't
stoic and do you know what he was
obsessed with we talked about the the
college players coming out and he loves
he thinks the best player in the draft
is the number-two guy what's his name
RJ Barret no the other one John Marant
John Moran he thinks John Marant is a
miracle aid should you be saying this I
don't care that I mean it's very West I
know like if Jerry West iam other GM's
if they listen to you should pay
attention that's what I'm think I would
take him over Zion you know why cuz
Jerry West said I don't know enough but
a Jerry West but here's the thing no
talk some basketball with them talk to a
lot of basketball bout Steve Ballmer
during the game he's screaming for
defense he cares so much he cares so
much he's the richest owner richest
owner in sports forget basketball in
sports they're gonna get one if not two
without a doubt of these big free agents
because they're so well-run
yeah and Doc is the best Doc's good
friends with Larry David so I've gotten
to know doc a little bit the best do
they play golf together they play golf
together but do you know what Jerry West
was talking about and a half time do you
want to know what he was obsessed with
how about this
okay I'm gonna take a break let's take a
break and we'll find out after the break
participate I'm in the man cave and it's
delightful in it this is the New York
one we have a new one I know I'm gonna
come out and see it it's unbelievable
I'm driving all the way out okay on a
scooter
dressed like Abe Lincoln just to get
some attention okay
when we last left off Jeff Garlin from
the Goldbergs Curb Your Enthusiasm was
gonna tell an unbelievable story well I
don't feel unbelievable but two things
that Jerry West was obsessed about at
halftime okay and by the way I'm in a
room with him and Ballmer and the other
about our bombers got one pom-pom
partner
I cannot remember his name okay okay and
it's a few people he was obsessed with
two things there was an article in The
New York Times which I had read about
how this one company out of Italy
charges so much money for prescription
glasses like prescription glasses should
be next to nothing and this one company
has made it so expensive and he was
incensed I was too but hearing Jerry was
and then he was also one sense that a
lot of the local businesses in his
hometown have gone out of business
because of Amazon and he was incensed
the whole time and Palmer is very much
about a free market and do what you do
they didn't argue but Steve Lee smile as
Jerry was going off on this we were
talking during the commercial break
about can you be too good-looking to be
funny
can ya like we and we have a theory that
if if Brad Pitt we didn't know Brad Pitt
as an actor but he came out on stage as
a smiley Cooper as a standard that could
not do it because I have to have a skill
level here's the thing you can pull it
off
but you have to have as good-looking you
are you have to have a skill level that
high you know be that funny like Dane
Cook yeah everybody was younger he was
funny you know yeah I mean funny enough
and and good look little too
good-looking no but here's the thing
there's a group of comedians and and by
the way I'm not begrudging them there
in this way and I'll put Dane as one of
them crystally as another one these are
guys that look like in high school they
were bullies and to me from David
Letterman all around in all directions
comedians we're the underdogs we're the
little guys and we point out hypocrisy
and what's funny and make fun of it
we're not the bullies so there's a whole
group now that come off to me like I
don't I think I don't want to say that
Dane or Chris aren't funny because they
are funny and they're talented but to me
there's a vibe of you picked on people
you know what I mean and I came from I'm
one of the little guys I heard let him
reason I included letterman at the
beginning was Letterman talked about
that in high school being you know I had
a weird high school experience for a
comedian I was the most popular kid in
school like the kid when you're the
class clown you're usually an outcast
you know everyone goes oh god I was a
classical huh and how were you treated
royally
I mean basketball star oh you play
basketball later got a cheerleaders
girlfriend you know I don't vocal
pumpkin patch with my family and so it
would've been fun to grow up in a
pumpkin patch what's your family do
pumpkins anyhow no I think that there's
a group but as I mentioned Sarah
Silverman she broke through with thee
because she's so beautiful
and she is equally as funny as beautiful
she is
see that's why she's the exception most
other beautiful women do not become
great comedians I had a real
embarrassing moment with Sarah Silverman
what happened I was on Jimmy Kimmel
uh-huh and I didn't realize they were
dating they just started dating and all
of a sudden Sarah Silverman's off to the
side she's not on stage just so
over there and she's going like this and
right now Alanis Morissette was the
guest you know she was on with Jimmy the
whole week and reading so we're just
sitting there as Alanis Morissette's
over here singing and I I think Sarah
Silverman is waving it you Damon me so
she's going like this and then you know
and I'm going man I'm killing out here
yeah
and so commercial break she starts to
walk up I get up out of my chair you're
a loser and then I I was like I don't
know what's gonna happen here but I
think it's go time right and she walks
over and gives him a little kiss Lego oh
boy but here's the thing she didn't
notice you if she was in Sarah is a
commitment to like that so she only saw
Jimmy she didn't see you making an ass
here so okay so know that she knows now
but I told her the story or just I'm
just saying it yeah yeah no you if you
see her just say but trust me she did
not notice I said it to Sandler because
Sandler grew up with Sarah Silverman and
I and I told him the story and you know
he was like Danny Danny what's wrong a
lega yeah I there's the scene in
swingers yeah at the very end when Vince
Vaughn is in the diner yeah and there's
the mother and she's got a baby and
she's you know I'm doing a reality show
with Vince Vaughn Vince Vaughn Tom
Morello and I are doing a reality show
on Marella yeah so ask me what channel
it's on or where it's gonna be where's
it gonna be Jeff I have no idea ask me
what it's about
you have no idea either no we started
filming at Cubs opening day we started
filming we have a crew we started
filming a reality show and it was
hysterical I don't know what it's about
and I don't know where it's gonna be so
this is three ships are financed by the
way yes three she comes Morelos yeah yep
yep diehard white why don't you just
call it I don't know what it is but
we're by the way I think it's we don't
know we're figuring it out but by the
way it's already like paid for and being
filmed is it green lit or green lighted
it's Greenland Greenland making and it's
paid for don't know what it's about
yeah and it was conceived two weeks ago
I'm Vince Vaughn and I conceived it two
weeks ago and Vince goes what about
Tommy Morello I got done swear to God I
wouldn't put you three together right
it's not exactly yeah two of us Oh Tom
Morello is the wild card no matter what
by the way we're looking to him for the
comedy I'm totally kidding although he's
got a great sense of you just let him
play guitar oh my god The Ghost of Tom
Joad when he goes like Springsteen come
on unbelievable online to YouTube when
the show's over
and of course and watch him rip it rip
it and you've got some pretty good
guitar players in that in Springsteen's
bands yes they almost like bow down to
Marella you got Frank in here some do
that live and that blew my mind
do you remember first time you run let
him yes I do like it was yes I remember
not sleeping for two nights before
literally going almost 48 hours without
sleep I was so excited I had a dream
when I did sleep prior to that of
bombing which I'm not a negative guy and
let him in behind me shaking his head no
I remember standing in the wings and and
they started playing my intro music
which got to give it up by Marvin Gaye
is what I requested and what's the
gentleman's name who pulled the curtain
Biff Biff Henderson and he pulled the
curtain and a calmness and the Ed
Sullivan Theater came over me because I
had my friends my friend's girlfriend
had said to me a week before you know
you're doing what you're supposed to be
doing
and to myself in that moment I went I'm
doing what I'm supposed to be doing and
I went out and killed it but aren't you
listening for Letterman's laugh at all
well I don't yes of course and I heard
it and I knew I was destroying and I
just knew he's got to be digging this
and he did so it was it was one of the
great movies you invited over yes yeah
yeah yeah it was it was it's always I I
hated being on Letterman really yes I've
never comfortable well he doesn't made
us come by and say hello no and then I I
was on Leno and Jays back therefore let
me tell you something out the Jay Leno
thing all right so I do Leno Show and
there's a package in my dressing room a
little box before I go out I go out it
comes by and he says hello he's very
warm and welcoming I go out and there's
a queue for me to tell a story I've
brought a cup which I actually have
which the Cubs gave away at their games
with them with a Coke or Pepsi of a Cubs
outfielder jumping in the ball how much
time do I have Seaton 3035 quick I don't
want to do it so his cue for me to tell
the story cuz they worked at ahead of
time is a senior from Chicago a he gave
me the cue twice had already done it
home in the car I open the box it says
great job tonight he told me that book
done the show that's the opposite of
comfortable foot Letterman he's Jeff
Garlin the Goldberg's Curb Your
Enthusiasm and Caroline's tomorrow night
through Sunday great to see you but an
honor to be here I look forward to the
new studio for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app